ein machtwort kommt aus karlsruhe ein
paukenschlag donnert durchs netz mit dem
heutigen urteil werden grenzen gezogen
was muss man sich auf social media
gefallen lassen und was nicht und was
heißt das jetzt für diejenigen die hass
und hetze absondern und vor allem auch
für diejenigen die sich dagegen wehren
hass oder meinung wo ist die grenze das
ist unser thema heute und damit herzlich
willkommen hier bei zdf heute live wie
immer könnt ihr eure fragen und
meinungen im chat abgeben oder auch auf
dieser eingeblendeten adresse unter zdf
heute - live at zdf de den stein ins
rollen gebracht hat die grünen
politikerin renate künast
reden wir nicht über sie sondern mit ihr
und schalten live nach berlin guten
abend renate künast
hallo ihr erster tweet heute morgen
lautete der tag fängt gut an in sachen
demokratie hatten sie damit gerechnet
dass das bundesverfassungsgericht ihnen
der den rücken stärkt
ich hatte nicht unbedingt damit
gerechnet nur gehofft aber als ich
gerade den beschluss in der hand hatte
per mail habe ich gezittert ohne mehr zu
verraten wo ein guter tag in sachen
demokratie das war der augenblick wo ich
es gesehen habe ich habe gewonnen welche
reaktionen sms whatsapp was auch immer
haben sie denn seither bekommen
massenhaft es gibt leute die rufen im
büro an und sagen was ich immer mal
sagen wollte danke dass sie so lange
darf weiter fahren
es hat mails gegeben bei twitter und
instagram also überall wurde eigentlich
sehr stark positiv
reagiert weil die leute wissen ja dass
ich seit langer zeit da dran bin an
diesem thema und da immer meine männer
überzeugt davon die zukunft der
demokratie wird im netz entschieden und
das den satz erreicht seit 12 jahren und
ist ehrlich gesagt wird mit dabei immer
blümerant weil es ich merke wie intensiv
er stimmt und die wie der ganze
sprachduktus und diese vorgehensweise im
netz und das manche damit noch
wahnsinnig viel geld verdienen uns
wirklich verändert also auch in der
analogen welt ja auf youtube gibt es ein
kommentar von hans jürgen krings sehr
begrüßenswert das urteil ich freue mich
für frau künast und muss gestehen dass
ich mir eine gewisse schadenfreude nicht
verkneifen kann wenn ich mir vorstelle
wie den helfern bei der veröffentlichung
des richterspruchs die kinnlade bis auf
die tastatur runter geknallt ist
gegenfrage gab es dann auch reaktionen
die ich schon wieder wert werden gerade
wieder juristisch aktiv zu werden
ach so weit habe ich nicht geguckt
wahrscheinlich muss ich da speziell bei
facebook gucken also bei twitter gab es
hier und da mal leute die gesagt haben
auch ihr wollt uns jetzt alle ihrem die
meinung verbieten und so aber da bin ich
jetzt ganz kühl ich weiß ja dass das
kommunikative trick ist also man will
eigentlich hartz üble nachrede
verleumdung verbreiten falsche zitate
erfinden und verbreiten und dann tun die
so als ginge es dabei um
meinungsfreiheit leider geht es ja nicht
darum ich nehme ein anderes wort macht
kritik das hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht auch benutzt es
geht ja nicht darum sozusagen an macht
bundestagsabgeordnete regierung oder so
inhaltliche kritik zu äußern sondern da
kann man gar nicht diskutieren das sind
persönliche herr abwertungen und wir
wissen ja alle dass es szenen gibt bis
hin zu der partei afd alle verbunden
sind die das geschäft systematisch ich
sage auch orchestriert betreiben damit
menschen sich zurückziehen 63 prozent
der frauen in diesem land sagen bei
umfragen sie würden ihre politische
meinung oder auffassung zu bestimmten
gar nicht ding mehr äußern
weil sie angst haben vor dem sturm der
dann zurückkommt und das ist doch klares
zeichen dass wir in ein massives
demokratisches defizit reinlaufen
schauen wir mal genauer darauf warum
eigentlich geht und da wollen wir uns
ein bisschen zeit nehmen denn da muss
man wirklich genau sein wir werfen einen
blick zurück
1986 war es da gab es die debatte im
berliner abgeordnetenhaus das thema
gewalt gegen kinder in familien ein
abgeordneter fragt eine parlamentarierin
wie sie zu dem antrag der grünen in nrw
stehe die strafandrohung wegen sexueller
handlungen an kindern aufzuheben und
dann haben sie frau künast den damals
den zwischenruf gemacht komme wenn keine
gewalt im spiel ist ein rechtsextremer
netzaktivist macht das 2009 10 auf
facebook zum thema und verfälscht ihr
zitat indem er daraus macht komme wenn
keine gewalt im spiel ist komma ist sex
mit kindern doch ganz okay ist mal gut
jetzt ja und dann ging es los kommentare
weit unter der gürtellinie wir sehen
hier nur mal ein paar und da haben wir
uns ehrlich gesagt schon die nicht ganz
so schlimmen rausgesucht gehirn
amputiert kranke frau oder die alte hat
einen dachschaden und wie gesagt da gab
es noch schlimmere kommentare was
dachten sie damals als sie das lasen
also es ist ja so langsam hochgekommen
ja ich muss sagen einmal war ja die
große verwunderung dabei was ist das
jetzt eigentlich für eine methode
sozusagen so kacheln zu entwickeln es zu
entwickeln da
zitate zu verfälschen also es gibt auch
ein anderes zitat von mir behauptet wird
ich hätte gesagt integration beginnt
damit dass die deutschen allemal
türkisch lernen oder so und da sah man
richtig wie das hier oder da mal auf pop
ich habe angefangen rechtlich gegen
dieses erfundene zitat vorzugehen da
merkst du aber es taucht überall wieder
auf wie soll ich jetzt wieder rausfinden
ich kann nicht ständig fachleute
beschäftigen die herausfinden wo ist
eigentlich der urheber von dem ganzen
oder wäre es ja ich kann mal gerade
herausfinden wer es jetzt gerade hat
hochkochen lassen und dann kamen
daraufhin ja all diese diese
die us post wo ich dann irgendwann mal
angefangen habe einige von denen zu
verklagen sowohl also einmal
strafanzeige zu stellen strafanträge zu
stellen und auf der anderen seite auch
zivilrechtliche klagen einzureichen
und das aber bei dem punkt ja genau sie
wollen von facebook die daten oder dass
wir das noch an der stelle erklären wer
genau hinter diesen kommentaren stellt
am ende ging es um 22 kommentare
war da nicht ihnen klar wie soll das
gehen wollten sie die jeanne d'arc sein
oder war die gefahr groß dass sie da
gegen windmühlen kämpfen
wie in diesem dieser geschichte mit dem
kampf gegen windmühlen sind ja glaube
ich gar keine windmühlen da oder das war
eine vorgabe veh konzentration oder
fokussierung nee also ich muss ja um
leute verklagen zu können jetzt straf
oder zivilrechtliche sich ja irgendwie
an adresse rankommen eine person
annahmen oder so und da habe ich mir 22
fälle rausgesucht und wir hatten der
bundestag hatte vorher mal im rahmen
dessen netzwerk durchsetzungs gesetz
einen paragrafen 14 beim
telemediengesetz verändert da steht drin
dass wenn ein gericht entscheidet das
was eine straftat sein könnte es quasi
mit dieser entscheidung die plattform
verpflichten kann daten herauszugeben
wie ip-adressen und so weiter so dass
ich sagen also aus finden kann wenig da
verklagen muss das ist ja eine
vorschrift die eines wollte nämlich dass
trotz anonymität im netz es nicht so ist
dass das netz ein ort weil sie vom
verleumdung falsch zitaten und übler
nachrede oder keine ahnung was erst um
beleidigung ist und an bedrohung ist
sondern dass die persönlichkeitsrechte
anderer den und auch vertreten werden
können und da hat dann das landgericht
berlin in einer im september 2009 10 in
einer sagenumwobenen entscheidung gesagt
ich als politikerin müsste das alles
hinnehmen dann haben sie noch gesamtes
gelben sachzusammenhang also da gibt es
ja ein wort entspreche ich es einmal
ausdrückte
da haben sie doch tatsächlich gesagt das
hätte ein sachzusammenhang zu dem zitat
wo es um pädophilie ging da hab ich bin
selber juristin habe zwei staatsexamen
da war ich da stand eine wirklich der
mund offen und viele juristen szenen
waren vollkommen entgeistert mal ganz
abgesehen
von dass ich gesagt habe das ist gar
kein zitat von mir und dass da auch
rechtlich gegen vorgegangen war also das
war eine krude geschichte ich habe
beschwerde eingelegt das berliner
oberlandesgericht genannt kann man
gericht hat ihn haben wir am ende in
zwölf fällen abgeholfen blieben zehn und
jetzt wollte ich es wissen deshalb dann
mit einer verfassungsbeschwerde nach
karlsruhe weil mich ich sag mal was mich
immer stört dieses das in der alten
rechtsprechung immer meinungsfreiheit
über alles gehalten wird und man könnte
dann sofern es überhaupt eine
meinungsäußerung ist und nicht eine
schlichte beleidigung meinungsäußerung
heißt ja dass es mit ihnen diskutieren
will und dass sich daraus was entwickelt
ja und nicht du sie scheiße aus du bist
so du bist krank oder was auch immer
ist ja keine diskussion sondern das
zielt nur auf die person und nicht auf
den inhalt über den man da reden könnte
eigentlich zeit entschieden hat der
einen stelle würde ich gern noch mal
einen haken weil ich glaube das war ja
weil sie so kraft die seinen weg ging
aber das war ja wichtig sie hatten
sozusagen damals nach diesem ersten
urteil schriftlich dass sie sich das
gefallen lassen müssen das war ja das
was tatsächlich für für großes aufsehen
gesorgt hatte wie war das denn damals
bei ihnen ging es dann wirklich ums
prinzip dass sie sagten das darf so
nicht stehen bleiben oder waren sie auch
persönlich verletzt
also es ist auch eine persönliche
vernetzung gleichwohl ich ja sage ich
mal jetzt schon böse gewisser weise nach
laden hier an politik gesteht bin und es
mich nicht aus den schuhen haut aber
aber es ist so was wie das muss ich mir
nicht gefallen lassen und zwar nicht von
den personen die sie schreiben und auch
nicht von zwei richterin einem richter
am landgericht berlin ja dass die und
ich habe das richtig für
geschichtsvergessen und juristisch
gehalten also es gab mal einen
verfassungsrichter böckenförde hieß da
der lebt nicht mehr und da hat man vor
vielen vielen jahren dass so erkennen
alle juristin juristen in der ausbildung
das böckenförde diktum geschrieben
nämlich der hat gesagt der demokratische
rechtsstaat lebt von voraussetzungen die
er selber gar nicht schaffen kann
nämlich der dass es eine
zivilgesellschaft gibt die
demokratischen prinzipien und gewalten
tragen nicht kritiklos tragen und das
hieß eigentlich einfach übersetzt das
eben nicht legislative exekutive und
judikative
dichte und dann auch unabhängiger medien
allein den demokratischen rechtsstaat
ausmachen sondern dass es eine
zivilgesellschaft auch die das
unterstützt woran es in der weimarer
republik übrigens meinte und wenn ich
dann sehe dass richter meinen und
einsatz sagen politiker müssen so was
aushalten da habe ich gesagt so nicht
mit mir da machen wir weiter das kann ja
nicht sein wer würde sich denn das
wissen wir doch wie wie auch kleine
ehrenamtliche bürgermeisterin
bürgermeister auf irgendeinem dorf
angefeindet werden per mail per so
plakate drüben mittlerweile gibt es
demos vor dem privathäuser und der rest
der familie leidet mit ich sag mal
einfach da ist für mich der also dann
gehen bei mir alle kerzen an das ist ja
seit dem seit 19 noch schlimmer geworden
daher soll sich denn für dieses land
noch engagiere ja ja ja so wie ich bin
das land noch mal kurz bei derlei nicht
geschützt wird also bei dem das
landgericht war dann gab es das nächste
instanz und heute dann um das noch mal
zu formulieren das urteil vom
bundesverfassungsgericht dass ihnen
jetzt wirklich voll und ganz recht
gegeben hat was diese 22 kommentare
anbetrifft da wird es also darum gehen
dass diese fälle neu aufgerollt werden
müssen und sie am ende dann
wahrscheinlich auch die daten bekommen
aber jetzt erstmal bei dem urteil heute
selbst das war ja wie sie gerade sagten
ein beschwerlicher weg und nicht jeder
ist ja auch gewillt und in der lage das
auszuhalten sie waren bundesministerin
aber sie haben es ja schon gesagt da
gibt es ja die vielen anderen was
bedeutet aus ihrer sicht dieses urteil
heute
also ich finde dieses urteil des
bundesverfassungsgericht ist für alle
alle sie sich engagieren und da steht ja
auch drinnen ein ganz wichtiger satz der
wo unter anderen entscheidung auch schon
mal andeutungsweise stand nämlich dass
es ein öffentliches interesse daran gibt
die persönlichkeitsrechte von menschen
die sich öffentlich und überhaupt
engagieren auch zu schützen das ist
sozusagen öffentliches interesse das
wären stehender begriff in vielen
rechtsbereichen das ist sozusagen das
interesse der allgemeinheit des
funktionierenden staates dass er hat ein
interesse muss sich dafür einsetzen also
das bezieht sich nicht nur auf
bundestagsabgeordnete amtsträger sondern
auf menschen die sich engagieren deshalb
habe ich vorhin das böckenförde diktum
der stadt eine demokratische staat lebt
von einer zivilgesellschaft die sie auch
unterstützt und für die prinzipien ein
chat und das ist quasi die fortführung
ich würde sagen
dieses alte diktum hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht ins 21
jahrhundert ist digitale zeit haben
alter gehoben und deshalb gesagt es ist
ein öffentliches interesse die
persönlichkeitsrechte von menschen die
sich engagieren zu schützen und deshalb
kommen sie auch zu dem punkt zu sagen
man kann mich einfach sagen was in der
alten rechtsprechung auf war
meinungsfreiheit geht eigentlich immer
vor und insofern ist es ein urteil für
alle und dann haben sie kriterien
aufgelegt also einmal haben sie das
kammergericht bisschen gebessert und
gesagt ihr habt nicht mal ordentlich
juristisch geprüft noch mal und sie
haben dann kriterien aufgelegt die eben
auch in dieses 21 jahrhundert geben und
die werden zivilgerichte die werden
strafgerichte staatsanwälte ab heute
binden und ich kann zwei punkte sagen
als erstes sagen sie falls irgendjemand
sagt na das ist mal so emotional einmal
gesagt worden getötet oder gepostet no
way sie sagen auch das ist ein
schriftlicher text vovo zugemutet wird
dass man eine gewisse zurückhaltung und
respekt vor anderen hat das ist
sozusagen nicht dass ich stehe auf dem
marktplatz und strom und streite mich
mit dem kameramann und dann sagt jeder
von uns mal was wildes hat sich dann weg
gesendet das kann man sagen in der
emotion nein hier sagen sie du gibst es
ist ein schriftlicher text deshalb kann
man nicht entschuldigen das ist eine
emotion war zweiter punkt die gerichte
müssen in zukunft berücksichtigen die
verbreitung und reproduktion das ist
auch klar sie müssen abwägen zwischen
meinungsfreiheit persönlichkeitsrecht
und dabei auch mit einbeziehen ob das
drei leute sehen oder hunderttausend
oder ob es sich reproduziert und nächste
woche oder in einem jahr wieder
auftaucht also der umfang der wucht
dieser beleidigung zum beispiel ist bei
dem punkt dass man das für strafbar
hätten mit zu berücksichtigen und
ordentlich abzuwägen also das ist das
was ja was besonders ist daran dass ich
bei mir braucht es auch ein zwei stunden
bis es sagte und dann die freude auftrat
jetzt gibt eine frage hier wird youtube
fragte haben sie das gefühl frau künast
dass sich die diskussionskultur durch
die sozialen medien verschlechtert hat
oder haben soziale medien auch eine
bereichernde dimension
ich fange mal mit dem positiven teil an
für mich hat es für mich persönlich hat
es auch eine bereichernde funktion waren
es nämlich ebene gibt wo ich mit anderen
kommunizieren kann überall auf der welt
leute die ich kenne oder nicht kenne von
dem man weiß dass man ähnliche
interessen hat oder über irgendwas
berichtet kann ich mich wunderbar
austauschen ja also man kann über
soziale medien kann mir auch
workers julian mit frauen die in der
textilindustrie in bangladesch arbeiten
mitteilen guck mal da passieren fehler
im auftrag deutscher europäische
unternehmen gut aber der ganz große teil
ist der gefährliche hier verdienen leute
geld richtiges geld mit klicks und die
meisten klicks sind bei emotion und
deshalb gehen die emotionen ohne ende
durch und wir haben ja gerade durch eine
wissen bremerin auch noch mal erfahren
youtube einfach auf junge leute so in
dem kontext gar keine rücksicht nimmt
ich habe eine sorge nämlich dass wir
immer mehr sozusagen nicht den teil
unseres gehirns wo verstand rat zu es
benutzen soll man da wo angst sorge
emotionen ist und das ist so eine neue
art der individualisierung und jeder
haut mal was raus ja ich weiß gar nicht
ob sie das lesen sie das ich fühle mich
jetzt besser und das ist fast wie so ein
korsett also das korsett der dieser
plattform und ihre geschäftsmodelle mit
diesem immer mal was raushauen immer mal
und so loslegen dass das animiert noch
weiter das ist ja wie eine neue
sozialisation ja erziehung zu zur einer
aggressiver emotion und abgrenzen und da
ist meines erachtens eine gefahr darin
die noch größer ist als wir dachten aber
schon
jetzt gibt es ja dieses urteil was was
schließen wir jetzt daraus das urteil an
sich ändert noch nicht sondern das was
man daraus macht was werden sie jetzt
als nächstes machen gehen sie dann wenn
die nächsten instanzen sozusagen jetzt
die fälle wieder aufrollen die 22
kommentare alle durch also kriegen die
dann irgendwann mal post von ihnen oder
was ist das was sie mitnehmen aus diesem
tag heute und dann auch künftig machen
also es war jetzt beim
bundesverfassungsgericht noch zehn also
da will ich dann auch gucken ob es sinn
macht ob die leute noch gibt die
accounts am ende noch
und dann auch rechtlich weiter vorgehen
ja ich möchte dass das recht in
deutschland das netzwerk durchsetzungs
gesetz so zu sagen dass auch aufnimmt
ich möchte das was an europäischem recht
gerade in brüssel diskutiert wird
zwischen kommission dem minister reden
und dem europäischen parlament solche
dinge berücksichtigt und auch ist also
sieht und versteht in diesem bereich
dass die persönlichkeitsrechte in gefahr
sind und dass es am ende eine plattform
sind für rechtsextremismus für angriffe
auf menschen und dass wir da sagen
müssen nein da bauen wir eine mauer und
das akzeptieren wir rechtlich nicht wir
schützen auch kinder also es man könnte
ja den übergang jetzt auch machen zu
diesem sexualisierte gewalt die
sogenannte pornografie aber das ist gar
keine pornos sexualisierte gewalt an
kindern auch da müssen wir sagen damit
könnt ihr kein geld verdient es darf da
nicht verbreitet werden wir müssen in
dieser digitalen welt sorge tragen dass
nicht geschäftsmodelle also profite
milliarden profite mark zuckerberg sie
macht ja gemacht werden können und wir
am ende hilflos dastehen wie diese
gesellschaft verroht und da ist mein
urteil nur ein puzzlestück deshalb sage
ich das eine ist das urteil ich bin ja
froh dass mittlerweile richter
staatsanwälte auch fortbildungen machen
auch so verschiedene gruppen einladen
und fachleute auch an welt- oder auch
mich war neulich auf einer
polizeiakademie in niedersachsen die
sich also auch polizei für ihre
ermittlungstätigkeit versucht zu
verstehen was da passiert so also es ist
eine ganz nah ich sag's mal
werkzeugkasten an maßnahmen die wir da
haben müssen und wenn wir uns jetzt
nicht wehren werden wir in einer
individualisierten welt wo wir uns alle
zurückziehen weil wir den öffentlichen
raum scheuen müssen leben und dass das
genau gilt es zu verhindern deshalb ist
es jetzt auch ja so gut dass ich alle
engagieren und gut dass sich alle und
viele engagieren das müssen wir
unterstützen die zivilgesellschaft und
reden sie darüber wenn sie angegriffen
werden machen sie es nicht zum
alleinigen problemen und schreiben sie
eine anzeige vielen dank für die zeit
und für die einsichten und einblicke
renate künast danke nach berlin
politiker müssten noch politiker müssen
ein dickeres fell haben so heißt es es
muss möglich sein mächtige zu
kritisieren das ist durchaus justiziabel
aber es gibt eben auch grenzen was heißt
jetzt dieses urteil für nicht politiker
wie schaaf darf einerseits meine kritik
sein was darf ich äußern und sagen im
netz aber andererseits was muss ich
aushalten und was nicht wir sprechen
gleich mit hate verschaffen uns vorher
aber ein überblick über diese fragen
widerliche [ __ ] oder [ __ ] purer hass
ungefilterter aggression alltag in den
kommentarspalten betroffen sind längst
nicht nur prominente sondern tag für tag
tausende user auch ihnen kann der
beschluss aus karlsruhe hoffnung machen
die entscheidung hat große auswirkungen
auch auf privatpersonen nicht nur auf
politiker weil die richterinnen und
richter am bundesverfassungsgericht ganz
klar noch mal die grenzen der
meinungsfreiheit aufgezeigt haben und
sie haben sehr deutlich gemacht dass
eine äußerung die dazu dient mit debatte
voran zu bringen in jedem fall eher
zulässig ist wohingegen der äußerung die
darauf zielt gezielt eine person
emotional zu stigmatisieren
oftmals seien eine beleidigung und damit
auch strafbar ist und das gilt für
politiker und politiker und prominente
aber eben auch bei privatpersonen doch
was ist eine beleidigung was genau
strafbar die grenze nicht immer
eindeutig und dann ist da noch die frage
wie genau sich opfer von digitaler
gewalt wehren können helfen soll das
netzwerk durchsetzungs gesetz seit
gestern zum beispiel müssen
internetfirmen mutmaßlich strafbare
äußerungen eigentlich an eine neue
zentralstelle beim bundeskriminalamt
melden
das bundeskriminalamt hat jetzt die
möglichkeit von sozialen netzwerken die
klarnamen die echten identitäten von
mutmaßlichen tätern heraus zu verlangen
um dann auch strafverfolgung aufzunehmen
und die person die dort hätten zur
rechenschaft zu ziehen allerdings haben
google sowie der facebook-betreiber
meter klage dagegen eingereicht ausgang
offen es bleibt viel zu tun im kampf
gegen hass und hetze im netz
wir sprechen jetzt mit hey babe schon
vorher mal noch schnell auf deren
homepage auf der es heißt gibt dem hass
keine chance wir sind an deiner seite
und dann hält bietet betroffenen
digitaler gewalt ein kostenloses
beratungsangebot und prozesskosten
finanzierung menschen die online hass
und hetze erleben die beleidigt
verleumdet oder bedroht werden können
sich an uns wenden wir helfen allen die
selbst keinen hass verbreiten unabhängig
von nationalität hautfarbe religion
alter geschlecht sexuelle orientierung
politischer meinung und körperlicher
versehrtheit und die juristische stimme
von haye tate ist josephine ballon
anwältin und leiterin der
rechtsabteilung guten abend nach berlin
haben vorab was ging ihnen als erstes
durch den kopf als sie heute von dem
urteil gehört haben
ich habe mich natürlich genauso wie
renate künast auch waren wir nicht
darüber gefreut wir hatten ja mit einem
so weitreichenden erfolg was gar nicht
gerechnet und vor allem hat es mich sehr
gefreut dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht so explizit
auch die speziellen gegebenheiten in
sozialen medien eingegangen ist die
leider vorherigen urteilen oft
vernachlässigt worden sie haben mit hält
ethos verfahren auch finanziert um damit
ein zeichen zu setzen
ganz wichtig es ist unglaublich wichtig
solche fälle überhaupt vor gericht zu
bringen und eben auch bis in die
höchsten instanzen und sogar bis zum
bundesverfassungsgericht zu bringen denn
leider ist es so dass betroffenen kaum
zugang zum recht und der realistischen
bedingungen gewährt wir haben zu lange
verfahrens laufzeiten wir haben hohe
kosten die damit verbunden sind und
leider eben auch ein jahr schnelles
internet im vergleich zu einer sehr
langsamen justiz und das führt dazu dass
kaum jemand clark und somit auch die
gerichte kaum mit solchen sachverhalten
befasst werden und somit findet auch
keine rechtsfortbildung auf diesem
gebiet statt und die betroffenen kann
ihre ihre erfolgsaussichten einfach auch
viel schwieriger abschätzen wir haben
einige fragen dazu mpg channel schreibt
via youtube ich bin gespannt welche
konsequenzen das für die social media
konzerne hat zusammengefasst was ändert
sich ab heute
für die social media kanzler wird sich
wahrscheinlich durch dieses urteil
erstmal nicht so viel ändern aber für
die bewertung von
persönlichkeitsrechtsverletzungen im
netz und das bei allem nicht nur für
politiker und polizei sondern für alle
menschen denn das gericht klargestellt
dass immer auch bei beleidigungen die
leider auch richtig justiz oft gering
geschätzt werden und abgetan werden es
ist doch nur netz ist doch nicht so
schlimm das kann man doch auch einfach
ausschalten und dann muss man das nicht
mehr sehen dass auch diese beleidigung
ernst genommen werden müssen und dass
die gerichte den betroffenen eine
vernünftige abwägungsentscheidung
schulden wo alle umstände des
einzelfalls mit einbezogen werden und
das sind vor allem die besonderheiten
des internet die besonderheiten der
sozialen netzwerke die eben auch dafür
sorgen dass beleidigung eine ganz andere
qualität erreichen als früher eric dyson
schreibt via youtube wie gewährleistet
der staat in zukunft die möglichkeit
anonym seine meinung äußern zu können
wenn die daten des bürgers eingeklagt
werden können
die daten der bürger und bürgerinnen
kann nur dann eingeklagt werden wenn sie
straftaten begehen deswegen ist der
beste rat um nicht in diese situation zu
geraten keine äußerung delikte im netz
zu begehen niemand zu beleidigen
niemanden zu bedrohen dann kann einem
auch nichts passieren deswegen sind ja
auch die gerichte hier vorgeschaltet es
ist keineswegs so dass renate künast
oder andere betroffene einfach zu den
solchen media plattformen gehen können
und dort die daten der der täter und
täterinnen sich besorgen können sondern
sie müssen über ein gericht gehen und
das gericht muss feststellen ob eine
straftat begangen wurde und wenn das der
fall ist dann können die social media
unternehmen verpflichtet werden daten
herauszugeben um zivilrechtliche
rechtsdurchsetzung zu ermöglichen und
die es dringend notwendig damit sie
langfristig eben auf eine abschreckung
und eine langfristige veränderung der
gebacken wurden manchmal ist ganz
einfach einfach keine straftat gehen und
dann passiert einem auch nichts aber die
andere frage ist ja nicht längst alle
fälle und kläger sind so prominent wie
renate künast wer kommt denn sonst so zu
ihnen und suchthilfe
hague hat in den letzten drei jahren
mehr als 1600 menschen beraten und mehr
als 160 davon mit prozesskosten
finanzierung unterstützt davon sind
natürlich bei weitem nicht alle personen
des öffentlichen lebens aber wir
brauchen natürlich auch personen des
öffentlichen lebens so mutige frauen wie
renate künast die ich mit ihrer
geschichte in die öffentlichkeit
gehen um auch andere betroffene zu im
power
andere wird oft mit es sich an uns
wenden sind vor allem menschen die
marginalisierten gruppen angehören da
spielt mehrfach diskriminierung auf eine
ganz große rolle und wir sehen dass sich
viele aktivistin den anderen ständen
journalistinnen und auch natürlich viele
politiker innen vor allem dort aber auch
nicht nur der bundespolitik sondern in
der kommunalpolitik
ganz andere unterstützungsstrukturen
nämlich leider keine meistens
vorherrschen weil diese ämter oft auch
im ehrenamt ausgeübt werden gabriels
taucher schreibt auf youtube ich finde
hass und hetze im netz prima die leute
würden ihre wut sonst auf der straße aus
leben und dort tut es wirklich weh
teilen sie diese meinung
ehrlich gesagt nicht denn ja leider
haben wir ja auch an traurigen vorfällen
in der realität gesehen dass vor allem
auf die radikalisierung im bett zu
gewalttaten im analogen kann wir haben
die tötung von walter lübke erlebt wir
haben die gewalttaten von halo und hanau
erlebt die alle einen hintergrund hatten
der im netz begonnen hat mutmaßlich und
das zeigt uns dass vor allem gibt es
radikalisierung freunde die das netz
heutzutage bietet etwas sehr
gefährliches sind und dass dort eben
eine enthemmung stattfindet die sich
manchmal auch ins analoge leben
überträgt deswegen würde ich diese these
nicht unterschreiben nun hat ja der ein
oder andere mit sicherheit gezögert sich
mit facebook und co anzulegen oder eben
auch so ein prozess anzustrengen wie das
renate künast jetzt mit ihrer hilfe
getan hat was glauben sie denn welches
signal von diesem tag heute ausgeht
trauen sich jetzt künftig mehr weil man
mehr handhabe hat
das signal der heutigen entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgericht ist definitiv
eines was betroffenen von
persönlichkeitsrechtsverletzungen im
netz mehr sicherheit bietet es war
bisher ganz ganz schwer überhaupt ja
dahin zu kommen dass man betroffenen
sagen kann ja das ist mit guten
aussichten verfolgbar oder nicht denn es
war leider sehr glücklich und wir haben
unsere prozesskosten finanzierung so
unterschiedliche urteile erlebt und
zuletzt ja eben auf den beschluss in
sachen künast ja ich möchte jetzt nicht
wiederholen urteil wurde das ist völlig
in ordnung ist sie mit wissen
schimpfwörtern zu bewegen das hängt den
betroffenen übrigens heute auch noch
nach es melden sich immer noch leute bei
uns die sich uns nicht glauben dass das
was sie erlebt haben möglicherweise
strafbar sein könnte weil das ja so
bezeichnen kann und dass eine
gerichtsentscheidung darüber gibt das
heißt die das signal an die betroffenen
ist definitiv ermutigen es gibt rechte
und die besonderheiten des internets
sind definitiv dafür relevant um eben
auch da hin zu kommen ja die schwere die
persönlichkeitsrechtsverletzungen im
netz erreichen zu würde was raten sie
mit den erfahrungen die sie hier täglich
machen ist es das wert sich zu wehren
ich habe natürlich vollstes verständnis
dafür wenn menschen tagtäglich mit hass
kommentaren oder auch anderen wegen im
netz übersät werden und sich sagen ich
kann nicht gegen jeden dieser hass
kommentare bord
grundsätzlich lohnt es sich aber
natürlich dagegen vorzugehen wenigstens
gegen die dinge bei denen man wirklich
sagt hier wurde eine grenze
überschritten
denn nur wenn tatsächlich auch fälle
berichtet werden wenn strafanzeigen
gestellt werden wenn auch mal betroffene
tatsächlich dem cd gerichtlichen weg
wähle dann
merken wir auch dass ich in der
gesellschaft verändern dass die behörden
und die justiz auch eine evidenz haben
und sehen dass es nicht nur traurige
einzelfälle wo man jetzt irgendwie mal
den weg gehen kann sondern das ist
tatsächlich auch deutlich wird dass das
thema eine gesamtgesellschaftliche
relevant sagt die ernst genommen werden
muss und die ganz ganz viele leute
betrifft denn das ist die realität
renate künast hat es vorhin angesprochen
und auch im beitrag haben wir es vorhin
gehört das netzwerk durchsetzungs gesetz
internet wir müssen eigentlich
mutmaßlich strafbare äußerungen an eine
neue zentralstelle beim
bundeskriminalamt melden da wird aber
noch gerungen ändert auch das urteil
heute etwas daran meinen sie
das ist etwas was davon wahrscheinlich
unabhängig zu betrachten ist denn zum
beispiel beleidigungs delikte sind von
dieser meldepflicht dort eingeführt
werden soll gar nicht umfasst die gründe
warum sich jetzt die plattformen dagegen
wenden uns einen tick tock und twitter
auch schon klagen dagegen eingereicht
sind eher datenschutzrechtlicher natur
und sind dadurch begründet dass sie
massenhaft daten an das
bundeskriminalamt aus leiten ohne dass
jemals ein gericht eine juristische
einschätzung dessen vorgenommen das war
erwartbar das war quasi ein ja ein
stillstand des gesetzes mit am tage der
jetzt leider nicht mehr zu verhindern
ist und wir sind da auch sehr gespannt
auf die entscheidung der natürlich haben
auch wir als zivilgesellschaftliche
organisationen die ihn mit allem was sie
tut die meinungsfreiheit im netz
verteidigen möchte ein kritisches auge
auf so eine massenhafte daten aus
leitung
abschließend damit dieses urteil
wirklich nachhaltig ist oder nicht nur
jetzt kurz mal abschreckt und dann
irgendwann sich doch wieder hass und
hetze bahn bricht was muss passieren
damit es nachhaltig bleibt
wir müssen davon gebrauch machen wir
müssen die strafgerichte wir müssen
zivilgerichte mit solchen sachverhalten
befassen dann wird das urteil auch in
der fläche angewandt werden kann und
darum kommen die fachgerichte die
gerichte in ganz deutschland jetzt
einfach auch nicht herum denn die
relevanz ist natürlich auch die
strafanzeigen vorhanden wo die gleiche
abwägungsentscheidung am ende kommen auf
berg muss das heißt wir können
betroffene nur ermutigen strafanzeigen
zu stellen und ihre rechte tatsächlich
auch wahrzunehmen wo immer es ihnen
möglich ist oder sich auch hilfe zu
suchen zum beispiel bei einer
beratungsstelle behält um dann ja über
die weiteren schritte zu beraten damit
tatsächlich die justiz und getrunken
wird die dieses urteil umzusetzen so
vielen ballon vielen dank für die zeit
und für diese informationen und für
diese einsichten danke nach berlin ein
stück rechtsgeschichte im digitalen
zeitalter so hat renate künast das
urteil heute genannt ab heute aber muss
sich auch zeigen ob es wirkt in diesem
sinne danke für eure aufmerksamkeit
danke für eure kommentare und bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss